Hey
pardon me sir I think you have the wrong
car
what are we doing here what the hell is
going on I was sent to get you for a
reason there was a flower on the pillars
of flower in the bathroom like we're
important the only chance we have is if
all three of us go crazy on this guy who
is that maybe she can help us don't
worry he's not allowed to touch him he
knows what you're here for
he listens to me
my name's
Edwin Porter you nine I've never seen a
case like this before
twenty-three identities live in Kevin's
body who are you help me get out of your
head Regan you trying to trick me I'll
tell on you hunt you the clever one an
individual multiple personalities can
change their body chemistry with their
thoughts
someone's coming for you who's coming
the Beast there's a man here he ducted
us and he's going to kill me
we're meant for something something
horrible the world will understand now
the beast is real he's gone awful thank
the people and he'll do awful things to
you
tell me story tell me